go right over here right right over here
hi there
real quickly have you ever come close to
giving up and what's kept you going to
giving up to giving what up giving up
the entire business the career and
saying you know what i'm done i'm going
to sell annuities
well the one time i came close to giving
up
is
in the early 1960s
i was writing these comics
the way my publisher wanted me to
and i didn't like doing them that way
because he said
don't worry about dialogue or about
characterization just give me a lot of
action and fight scenes
and i was gonna quit
and my wife said if you're going to quit
why don't you just do one book the way
you want to do it get it out of your
system
the worst that'll happen is he'll fire
you but you want to quit anyway
so that's when i wrote the fantastic
four which was the way i wanted to do it
and because of that i got stuck in the
comic business so i would have been
better off quitting and not writing
all right
you